the Christ I came to know through his
grace I'll die for him any second
doesn't sound like he's
scared this is Bishop marari Emmanuel
who was recently attacked while his
sermon was being live streamed few
months ago he was on the pbd podcast and
he didn't seem too worried about threats
I'll die for him any second I do not
give one penny with all love and respect
no matter what happens because the
Christ that came and revealed himself to
this piece of rig is the only one he is
my king my Lord my God my savior My
Redeemer forever towards the end of the
interview the bishop started comparing
Jesus to the religious systems of the
world Christ is calling us to love him
he is not calling us to follow a set of
rules guidelines and regulations lots of
religions have rules but he's about to
zero in on one religion in particular
and let me say this to all the religions
of the world you're talking about you
must fast and you must do this and you
must you do your penances and whatever
you have to do recite the shahada pray
the five daily prayers give zakat take
the pilgrimage and fast during
Ramadan will doing these things ever be
enough let me say this to enter in the
presence of God who can do what what God
wants who can fulfill the fullness of
the law of God we are nowhere near that
Perfection to do and abide by what God
does following your religion's rules
isn't good enough because you won't
follow them perfectly some people found
that one out the hard way he showed that
in the Old Testament the Israelite
Nations they failed him from the word go
till the very end but he is the never
failing God his Mercy that carries us
and this is a good way to lead into the
gospel so when those religions out there
with all love and respect they talk
about laws I'll ask them are you
fulfilling that law of course not you're
falling very short of that law so don't
tell me you have to do this where you
are failing as a leader so people fall
short of
perfection who else fell short your
Prophet failed those laws your own
Prophet failed them who Muhammad
Muhammad failed that's not what I heard
from the daah guys and the and the very
reason why Muhammad fail because he's
dead their book says that but their book
also says about my Messiah even though
the ISA in the Quran is not the Christ
of the Holy Bible totally separate
people but let me tell you one thing
your book says that Isa son of Mary went
up to heaven alive and he will come back
to judge the dead and the living
interesting Muhammad died but Jesus went
went up to heaven alive and he's going
to return to judge even in
Islam just ask the daah guys we will
inshallah wait for the true Messiah
which we believed which is Jesus peace
be on him he will truly come not claim
to be divine he will come and rather
kill the D thanks for the cosign Ali
dawa but why is Jesus the one who
returns to
judge if I ask a Muslim who judges they
will say God well you telling me this
Prophet will judge so which is which has
the prophet taken the role of God has
God gone on vacation and he's come and
take his position no but Isa is the
living Messiah even their book says he's
right the Quran does say that Jesus is
the Messiah Surah 3: 45 and remember
when the Angels said oh Mary Lo Allah
giveth thee Glad Tidings of a word from
him whose name is the Messiah Jesus Son
of Mary illustrious in the world and the
Hereafter and one of those brought near
unto Allah how else is Jesus special
even in Islam I speak Arabic I read
Arabic I'm fluent in Arabic when they
say buta son of Mary Jesus Son of Mary
is the word of God and the spirit of God
the bishop is right again Allah said
says Christ Jesus the son of Mary was
and the translators add in parenthesis
no more than an apostle of God and his
word which he bestowed on Mary and a
spirit proceeding from him verse goes on
to attempt to deny the doctrine of the
Trinity and the sunship of Christ but
that doesn't explain why Jesus is the
word of Allah and a spirit proceeding
from Allah you see according to the
Quran when Allah creates he says be and
things pop into
existence but Allah's word comes from
within Allah himself and the spirit is
something that Allah breathes out so why
would Jesus be Allah's word and a spirit
proceeding from
Allah if you're claiming Isa is a
prophet then how come all the other
prophets which you believe in you
believe in Moses you believe in Isa you
believe in all the prophets of the Old
Testament how come none of the Old
Testament prophets were referred to as
the word of God except Isa why why is
Jesus so different even in
Islam how come all the prophets and
every single human being on the face of
this planet was born of an Earthly
father and an Earthly mother yet Jesus
Son of Mary was born in a virginal birth
through a virginal birth he has an
Earthly mother but has no earthly father
for his Father Who Art in Heaven the
standard Muslim response here is that
Adam was created without a father or a
mother but that doesn't address the
problem Adam was created without a
father or a mother because there were no
other human beings Allah had to create
Adam
miraculously but by the time Jesus was
born there were plenty of human beings
around so why did Allah break the course
of nature to once again make sure that
Jesus is completely
unique even in
Islam why this raises question marks how
come this man is different his birth is
different his life is different even his
end is different he went up
alive and he will come back to judge
here the only answer you'll get is Allah
law knows best which is another way of
saying we've spent 14 centuries trying
to figure out why Jesus is so radically
different from everyone else even in
Islam but our greatest theologians
haven't been able to discover a reason
so we'll just say Allah knows best Jesus
is different from everyone else even
from all other prophets in Islam and
Muslims have no clue
why but I bet Bishop marari can explain
why Jesus is radically different from
everyone else even in
Islam because he is different that's the
whole story he is different my dear
friend because he is the Living God who
was revealed in the flesh he is the
logos the Alpha and the Omega the
beginning and the end he is the way the
truth and the life and there is no one
else that is a better explanation than
we've ever gotten from the dawa guys but
please tell us more about Jesus he is
the king of kings and the Lord of lords
yesterday he is today he is and forever
more he is he is the never changing God
who was revealed in the flesh over 2,000
years ago but is Islam right about the
crucifixion and he was crucified not he
was sent up to heaven no he was
crucified he died in the flesh on the
cross and he was buried but rose from
the dead on the third day ascended to
heaven and he's been sitting there at
the right hand of the father over 2,000
years ago so that's why Jesus is the one
who's going to return to judge and he
will come back again to judge the dead
and the living because he's not just a
prophet for he is God revealed in the
flesh this is the Jesus I talk about
that's why I fear no one I fear nothing
makes way more sense than the Islamic
view but I wonder if the good Bishop has
anything else for us Jesus Christ I not
only believe in him dear Patrick I know
him you mean you know about him like
from reading or something I say this
with absolute humility the Lord Jesus
revealed himself to this piece of wreck
I don't speak about Jesus just because I
believe I'm a Christian or I dress up in
this cloth or I have read the Bible
which I have no well if you're not
talking about Jesus because you're a
Christian or because you've read the
Bible what are you saying I believe in
the Lord and I know the Lord is 6' one
long face tan skin greenish eyes brownie
crispy hair split in the middle all the
way to the shoulders with a very short
bead Jesus is 6' one you measured his
height when did this happen he has
showed me heaven and
hell and let me say this with love and
humility when you go to heaven I can ass
show you I can ass show you not because
I'm a Christian not because I'm a bishop
not because I believe in Jesus Christ
but I can assure you in heaven you
Muhammad will not greet you Noam alayum
from Muhammad then Muhammad will not
greet you Buddha will not greet you
Krishna will not greet you because they
will not it was it will be only one who
is the way the truth and the life who's
that again it will be Jesus Christ of
Nazareth who died for you and me I'm
inviting you to accept Jesus as Lord and
savior because there is no other way if
we don't have him we are doomed forever
for in him eternal life lies
whoa the gospel is powerful no wonder
the bishop isn't scared when I meet
Jesus I see everyone a piece of dust
what can a man do to me oh they can kill
me welcome death Bishop marari Emmanuel
said all of this and more on a podcast
that got millions of
views now do you understand why he's got
a Target on his back
[Music]